ce qui est important c'est de prendre en
compte les institutions bien sûr et leur
évolution
je crois qu'on va vers davantage de
maturité de part et d'autre auparavant
il y avait peut-être un peu de un peu de
crainte devant les évolutions
institutionnelles
il est évident que le représentant de
l'état s'inscrit pleinement dans ses
évolutions là et que l'important c'est
de développer un partenariat très étroit
aider au mieux je crois que c'est là un
peu le rôle de l'état on dit souvent
assurer la liberté assurer la sécurité
jean roch c'est une mission principale
de l'état aux comptes aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales quelles
qu'elles soient et quels que soient bien
sûr l'heure le cadre institutionnel dans
lesquelles elles s'inscrivent quelle
sera votre première action
je crois qu'il faut que le représentant
de l'état doit s'attacher à la sécurité
je crois que c'est vraiment ce que les
citoyens attendent je suis je pense que
je suis avant tout là pour ça évidemment
il ya le défi économique assurer la
prospérité la lutte contre le chômage
qui est quand même un point préoccupant
donc je crois qu'il faut marcher sur les
deux jambes de la sécurité qui puisse
permettre d'atteindre un niveau
économique qui soit satisfaisant il n'ya
pas l'un sans l'autre je pense